I also think this is the first time in
Conor's career he's fighting guy who has
more knockout power than him I believe
that for me but I also yeah I also think
he knows that which excites me you know
but you know everybody knows a typical
Michael Chandler fine man I'm gonna put
my foot on the gas get in his face put
him on his back foot early and yeah try
to knock him out my Mystic Mike
prediction I knock him out in the second
round I beat him up pretty bad wear him
down in the first make him second guess
himself and then bam hit him with a hard
one in the second he goes down and we
jump on the cage maybe a backflip we'll
see yeah maybe back flip I assume a
backflip oh I assume we're back did you